hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten welt heute gibt es wie
angekündigt das rezept für christus ist
ein türkischer salat da besteht aus
burgund buch uhr gibt es im türkischen
laden zu kaufen gibt es aber auch von
alnatura zum beispiel weiter
da müsste jetzt nur darauf achten da hat
verschiedene reinheitsgrad das zeige ich
euch gleich noch wenn ich die zutaten
vorstelle dass salat schmeckt natürlich
im sommer am besten da kann man das
frische gemüse aus dem garten benutzen
und ihr könnt bei den zutaten eigentlich
auch sehr variieren und die grundzutaten
stelle ich euch jetzt kurz vor
ich habe jetzt hier den feinen bongo den
gibt es auch mittel könig oder
grobkörnig das könnt ihr dann selbst
entscheiden wie er das möchte
da nehme ich jetzt zwei tassen davon und
dazu noch 2000 kochendes wasser
ihr braucht öl und eine große zwiebel
und dann braucht ihr noch tomatenmark
besser wäre natürlich sauter vom
türkischen laden und auch paprika markt
es gibt es hier auch so und zum
verfeinern braucht ihr dann noch eine
spitz paprika gurke tomaten und etwas
petersilie und zitrone und wer es noch
ganz lecker haben möchte kauft sich noch
so ein granatapfel sirup den gibt's auch
im türkischen laden und zuerst zeige ich
euch jetzt wie ihr den burghof
erarbeitet den bruno gebt ihr dann in
eine schüssel die ihr später mit einem
deckel verschließen könnt und bei diesem
feinen burg und nehme ich jetzt vogel
und wasser eins zu eins und sogar etwas
weniger wasser
das wasser ist jetzt frisch abgekochtes
kommt jetzt damit dazu ich nehme es hier
auch etwas weniger
schaut das ist schön abgedeckt ist und
dann kommt der deckel drauf
es bleibt so etwa zehn minuten stehen in
der zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal das
gemüse schneiden
zuerst nämlich dazu die zwiebel und ihr
müsst die schönen freien würfeln das
bildet von auch für das ganze restliche
gemüse den fein gewürfelt schmeckt das
später fehlt
die gewürfelte zwiebel gibt ihr dann in
euren kleinen topf ich werde nämlich
einmal andünsten viele machen das auch
so dass er das womit dazu geben aber ich
finds eigentlich an gewünschte schmeckt
viel besser da kommt auch ein großer
schuss öl mit dazu ich nehme da ganz
gerne geschmacksneutralen öl und das
wird dann bei mittlerer bis hoher hitze
angedünstet dann etwa fünf minuten sind
die zwiebeln etwas glasig gedünstet und
star kommt jetzt das tomatenmark und das
paprika markt mit dazu da gibt ihr
einfach so viel rein wie ihr mögt beim
essen etwa vier esslöffel ich gebe da
einen esslöffel von paprika markt mit
dazu da müsst ihr darauf aufpassen als
ich habe jetzt die scharfe variante die
gibt's auch in süß aber ich bin so kommt
die gute schärfe noch mit
dass wir das etwas mit gedünstet
und ihr seht ist hier das volumen hat
sich deutlich vergrößert und der burg
ist jetzt weit
das macht auch nichts wenn er etwas
länger steht aber wir verarbeiten den
jetzt gleich weiter und zwar kommt da
jetzt die betriebe tomatenmark maske
drauf berührt ihr dann alles schön
miteinander und noch besser klappt das
wäre das mit den händen verknetet da
müsste jetzt nur darauf aufpassen die
macht es nämlich noch ziemlich heiß
deswegen benutze ich eigentlich auch
handschuhe die schützen mich etwas von
vorder hitze aber nicht wirklich
und außerdem werden meine hände und
meine fingernägel nicht orange
so sieht es dann aus und während es
abkühlt könnt ihr schon mal das gemüse
vorbereiten
hier seht ihr habe ich die gurke etwas
geschält und die paprika hier habe ich
dieses kerngehäuse entfernen
wenn alles fertig geschnürt wird habt
seht das ungefähr so aus das wird jetzt
noch gebührt hier gebe ich etwas salz
mit rein
das heißt gebe ich es aber bewusst mit
zum pogo damit es nicht die feuchtigkeit
und die flüssigkeit aus dem gemüse zieht
dann kommt hier direkt noch die zitrone
mit rein
bei mir kommt dann da noch etwas
schärfer im sommer nämlich frischer
pfefferminze jetzt nehme ich aber
getrocknete und etwas oregano und dann
noch etwas von diesem granatapfel sirup
der hat so eine ähnliche konsistenz wie
balsamico creme ist dabei aber etwas
säuerlicher und auch etwas süßlicher
dann bricht das alles miteinander wenn
der rat vollständig abgekühlt ist könnt
ihr den mit dem salat vermischen
danach müsst ihr den salat nur noch
abschmecken und dann ist ja eigentlich
auch schon fertig das war eigentlich
schon alles nachdem das salat jetzt noch
mal durchgeführt wird könnten eigentlich
gravierend dass anna schmidt noch am
nächsten tag noch gut also der schon gut
1 bis 2 tage haltbar und dann wünsche
ich viel spaß beim nachmachen
wenn ihr fragen habt könnt ihr sie gerne
stellen ich versucht sie zu beantworten
und dann wünsche ich euch einen guten
appetit
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss